temple os an open source 64-bit
operating system designed to be the
third temple prophesized by the bible it
was created in 2005 by terry davis an
exceptionally talented programmer
diagnosed with schizophrenia he wrote
the entire operating system himself at
his parents house in las vegas which
included a bootloader kernel window
manager 3d graphics library and multiple
games all powered by his own compiler
and custom programming language called
holy c amazingly it all fits in under
100 000 lines of code at 1.4 megabytes
just as god intended he believed he was
god's chosen programmer and implemented
features described as a modern day way
of speaking in tongues it renders
graphics at 640x480 resolution limited
to only 16 colors the underlying
language holy c resembles c or c plus
plus but has functions that can be
invoked without parentheses or arguments
and uses just in time compilation which
means it doubles as a shell language
that can be executed directly from the
terminal unlike other operating systems
like linux or windows it's ring zero
only which means everything happens
directly in the kernel including user
programs you have complete control over
the operating system source code and
hardware that may not seem very safe but
it's the way it is because it's fun to
get started you'll first want to
download the iso file from the temple os
website from there use a tool like
virtualbox configured for a 64-bit
operating system that boots this file on
startup it creates a single immortal
task named adam it's the father of every
other task just like in the book of
genesis it can also take advantage of
multiple cpu cores where each core gets
its own immortal set task once inside
you can take the tour or immediately
start speaking in tongues by hitting f7
which generates a pseudo-random word
from god you can also have god draw you
a picture with shift f6 to perform a god
doodle that was fun but now use ctrl m
to open up the personal menu from here
you'll find a huge variety of games like
3d first person shooters 2d strategy
games and simulations like after egypt
where you play the role of moses and
also has utilities to manage your
finances and make music remember this is
all made possible by a custom graphics
library if you're not happy with the way
it works simply open up the source code
make some modifications and holy c
reboot and enjoy every line of code is
right at your fingertips thanks to the
red sea file system the end result is
one of the most complex pieces of
software ever written by a solo
developer but there's a lot more to this
story and sadly terry davis passed away
in 2018 at the age of 48. he was both a
highly controversial internet
personality and genius programmer this
has been temple os in 100 seconds hit
the like button if you want to see more
weird videos like this thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one